perfect placement too and these were all
wire gags these were nothing was cg at
all oh
is that you yeah
well that's definitely a stunt person
it's not a dummy
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get 15 off of your order what's
up everybody we are back another episode
of summon react we have lauren mary kim
joining us today for the second time you
guys may remember her from another
episode we did you were in the
mandalorian season too weren't you yes i
was season two i doubled costco reeves i
did a couple episodes of fennec and i
did the magistrate lauren has a lot of
insight and expert tips to talk about
here on the episode today so let's just
jump into it
so if you guys looking for an incredible
martial arts film to watch check out
angbok this is a film that has full
contact hits all over the place also
take note of how everybody's got kooky
hair because they all have wigs so they
can hide the pads on their heads because
tony jazz is going to come in through
the elbows and just
yeah that does not look real at all that
hair
come on
[Music]
oh
man
you think that was a real hit i mean
it's kind of a push it's probably sped
up a little bit you know under cranked
tony jackson's score on the guy's face
but the guy sells it too yeah totally i
think he just safely puts on his ear
almost which is way better than the face
[Applause]
that's full contact yeah
that's like a thigh right versus a knee
so it is his inside thigh but it's like
the knee is projecting behind his head
right behind here yep this is like this
is sleight of hand but for martial arts
i don't know is that a wig
we just know that the guy shows up with
crazy he's like oh he's gonna get hit so
hard
yeah polish
[Music]
that bounced
it's nice and close
dude i love there's nothing cooler than
a counter attack yeah kick for another
exactly okay perfect placement too that
is
i mean it hurt but not like gnarly at
all
the sneaky kick yes
little baby look at that dust that they
put on his shoe yeah to make that look
more sellable
he's coming after sonic's coming
oh
man i love the way this stuff is shot
it's very clear well because he doesn't
even have a stunt double yeah he's just
doing all of it that's how it is in asia
though they hire actors that can do
everything yeah like jackie chan like
all of them
out the windows
out the window
oh he goes with him
he's sleeping peacefully
yeah no harness either did you see a
shirt come up too yeah
i miss people getting like uppercuts
slash drop kicked out of windows
i miss those days
is that you yeah
awesome
oh
[Laughter]
that was a fun thing to do that's great
that's like so ballsy to be able to jump
backwards off of a rock just like i got
this no problem so robert rodriguez
actually directed that episode and he
wanted that version oh for real yeah
like a desperado like type pose but uh
john favreau wanted like a more parkoury
like move to get off um so they ended up
choosing this version though i i was
shocked because i didn't think they
would we were jumping onto a pad or
boxes uh yeah we had uh boxes the boxes
as far as i know is like the old school
way to do
a high fall so why bring boxes out as
opposed to just like a big
crash pad because sometimes the crash
map may not be um like big enough or we
don't have enough the boxes make you
actually crumple in more so you're not
rolling out jumping in boxes is really
kush like i prefer it actually nice yeah
you guys should try it well there's a
there's a scene in prism that we made
way back in the day on corridor and we
needed jimmy wong to do a fall off the
edge of a roof so we actually did the
fall off the edge of the roof of this
building onto a stack of boxes oh nice
yeah and jimmy did it yeah
how old is he like 10.
shout out to jimmy i mean this is a heck
of a stunt from the dew right here
dang wow
so when like having a fancy costume like
this
are you putting like a special like soft
one on for like the stunts or do they
just like here's your helmet yeah
sometimes we just can add some like
elbow pads and knee pads but as a woman
like you don't ever you know
everything's so tight so we have to wear
like thinner pads and like the guys can
wear all like the hard pads doing stunts
is difficult enough but doing stunts in
costume where yeah line of sight is
limited totally it makes it so much more
difficult yeah like do you have tricks
to deal with that or is it just
something that you need to get used to
you definitely have to get used to it
because you're you're not as mobile like
as if you're wearing like a like a
normal outfit but yeah i mean i did
power rangers for years like i did like
all the live shows and commercials
really yeah so i i had like a lot of
practice and helmets and that's like
really helped me with like the armor
fight the coaster reeves helmet like it
really helped a lot if you guys have any
awesome stunt work or fight scenes that
you guys would love to see broken down
on the show please leave a comment down
below read them maybe we'll take the
highest upvoted comment and we'll break
it down lauren i got
a stunt that i have been
very curious about i've been trying to
figure this one out for a minute and i'm
hoping that you could shed some light on
this one i'll fight you neville i'm
really really sorry about this
petrificus totality
[Music]
oh
well that's definitely a stunt person
it's not a dummy no i don't think so he
hits his head yeah but they probably
padded the ground and he went for it
it's so perfect though but he tucked his
chin because that's another trick that
we have is we tuck our chin so we don't
actually have crazier damage to our neck
now it looks like that's the kid though
you can see his face right there or it
could be a double that's really good do
they ever do stunt children like israel
they do have stunt children yeah
especially stunt guys kids they're like
hey yeah jimmy go do this
they just chuck them they like kick them
in and they're like get in
make some money from the family or it's
a girl doubling a little boy who's like
4-11 that had the same facial structure
as him i just think that's an insane
stunt and would be terrified to even
think about it right yeah so we did a
harry potter rated r thing and this is
actually one of the shots that we went
back to and we did i think ren's working
on it where he hits a gun shatters in
his skeleton stones
we're taking like a bunch of scenes and
turning them all brutal yes i love it
i'm putting together this new team to
get justice
this is our destiny
so star girl is the show i talked about
last time it's a dc streaming show it
just has so much cool action
so i double the yellow
cat woman in this one her name's tigress
does that see you right there yeah
sweet wow
oh
that one was a gnarly one so that was
shot really nicely yeah yeah they did it
in one
[Music]
we actually did that
wow so i slid under her on a wire and
then she did like her little kip up over
me and these are all wire gags these
were nothing was cg at all for us so it
was just really innovative stuff how do
you slide on the pavement without
scratching up everything we had um lexan
it's like a plastic clear
material that they use for sliding and
stuff because i don't even see it like
that's a nice little trick yeah i wonder
if they're taking it out in post oh yeah
definitely definitely but it's a clear
so it's easier to take out i think yeah
yeah but yeah and she's picked from the
hips oh yeah with gradles yeah what is
that yeah it's like a machine that they
drive in and then we put tres a tris
system built on top of that and then
we're able to rig on top of it so all of
it is in the air above us got it yeah
that's what we use for um shock troopers
back in the day yeah it's pretty
incredible what we can do with wires
nowadays and a lot of this is just
people holding onto ropes on the other
end
we have like 5 million riggers and like
there's one instagram post i did of like
it seemed like a simple gag but we had
like 10 rigors and it just takes so much
engineering and like physics and just
everything to think of like rigs that's
a lot of trust
yeah you know it's also a lot of trust
hey
how many followers do you guys have now
we have 4.6 million on the quarter crew
channel which is amazing
and we have 8.7 million on the corridor
channel please subscribe if you aren't
subscribed we appreciate it and helps
out our videos thank you you and me we
have someone to finish businesses on
[Music]
any ideas
just the usual so warrior i discovered
because my i actually know the stunt
coordinator and the action director um
johnny yang and uh brett chan and it
like takes place in like the late 1800s
when the chinese came to san francisco
and it hits home with me because my
family immigrated at that time and my
great great grandfather actually opened
up like an illegal gambling hall in
chinatown so i was like oh my god this
show is my life like my family so i i
mean i just love how they're telling our
our chinese-american story and the fight
scenes are
oh my god the best
so bruce lee was southpaw so that's how
he starts in southpaw what a southpaw uh
so regular stance would be left leg
forward fighting and then southpaw would
be right leg forward bruce lee chose to
fight like that because it was the
lesser known way they could throw people
off yeah exactly
[Applause]
what about this style of martial arts is
distinctly bruce lee so bruce lee
basically took all the good things that
he thought were strong in every martial
art and he created his own and that's
the thing it's like it could be your own
creation that it was like very
subjective it sounds very practical yeah
versus like oh it's got to be this style
or that style like everything else is
trash
these are the actors doing this yeah so
in their spare time they have to go
practice the choreography from the other
fights yeah yeah and then like also oh
you have to remember all my lines and
practice my scenes and get my emotional
connection to everything and then like
that's so much work so much work i don't
know how they do that
[Applause]
i just i just love it when it's clear
what's going on yeah and like you can
read the moves
and i'm getting a lot of that from this
even just from like the first minute oh
yeah which is so great to see yeah i
hate it when it's like i can't tell
what's going on yeah i think those days
are over i think a lot of people are
like a lot smarter and they don't want
to
be confused they just want to see clean
fights nowadays
hey everyone thanks for watching these
videos you know i want to give a shout
out to raycon for sponsoring these
videos and let you guys know that if you
are looking for a bluetooth wireless
earbud to put in your ears these are a
great option they come in a handy
convenient charging case which you
charge the case and then put the earbuds
in there for storage and they charge
themselves on top of that they fit your
ears really well have a great sound
profile they are noise isolating the fit
and they have a long battery life come
in a whole variety of colors you can
have fun with them and make sure that
they match your wardrobe and honestly
they're very very hard to shake loose so
if you like listening to music while
you're exercising these guys are really
good to go with on top of all that
raycon has a 45 day free return policy
if you guys are looking for a nice pair
of bluetooth earbuds definitely check
out raycon's use the link in the
description below to get 15 off
www.buyrecon.com core recruit thank you
so much for watching everybody
back to the outro of the episode thank
you so much for having me guys thank you
so much for coming out it's an absolute
pleasure you guys love seeing how the
magic is made in these action scenes and
these stunts lauren's instagram has a
bunch of great behind-the-scenes clips
and other examples of the work she's
doing you should go follow her at
laurenmarykim
see you guys next saturday